[MUSIC PLAYING]
WYATT GORMAN: Thanks
for joining us.
My name's Wyatt Gorman.
I am a high performance
computing specialist
with Google Cloud.
I'm based in New York City.
Thanks for joining us
at technical deep dive
into storage for high
performance computing.
Just quick show of
hands, how many people
know what high performance
computing is, what
kind of workloads there are?
And then keep them up.
And how many people are actually
users of HPC, or researchers,
or engineers, or sys
admins, or manage teams?
OK, great, about
half-- excellent.
So we have-- please,
first of all,
if you have any questions up
front or throughout the talk,
please put them on our new Dory.
It's an internal
system that we've
had for a long time that's
really helpful for just
submitting questions that
you might want to ask
and easily going through them.
So we have a great
lineup of speakers today.
Again, I'm Wyatt.
I have with me Dean from Google
Cloud as well as Sven and Minh
from DataDirect Networks.
And I'll let them
tell you a little bit
about what they're
doing with Google
Cloud in the marketplace.
But first, I just want
to talk about what
HPC is for those of
you who don't know,
aren't familiar with it.
So just some examples
of some industries
that HPC users
are in that really
is fundamental to
their industry--
manufacturing, so computer
aided design, chip design,
things like this, life
sciences, in terms of genomics,
financial services, climate
modeling, everything like that.
So as you might know,
for those of you
who do HPC, in these industries,
compute is the real driver.
So all the time questions
are getting bigger,
demands for compute are growing.
And so we see this, especially
in the top 500 supercomputers.
So this is a graph of the growth
of those systems in FLOPS,
which is floating-point
operations per second.
And so you can see that
we've grown now and exceeded,
in total capacity, an
exaFLOP of storage--
of performance-- I'm sorry.
And we're going to see the first
exascale system very shortly,
around 2021.
So all of this compute--
and also storage is
constantly growing.
So if you look at the last
10 years of storage growth,
we started in 2008 with
about three petabytes
on the largest system,
RoadRunner at Los Alamos.
That was about 55
gigabytes a second,
which was pretty
impressive for the time.
But in just 10 years, we've
83 x-ed the capacity to 250
petabytes in a single storage
system and gone up to 2 1/2
terabytes a second, which
is absolutely tremendous
the factors of scaling
that we're seeing,
not only in compute,
but also in storage.
And so all of these things
together, combining compute,
and combining storage,
and software, of course,
drives your mission.
It's not just about
infrastructure.
It's really about your science
and what you're trying to do.
So a great example of that
is the Broad Institute.
The Broad Institute is a
genomics research organization
and genomic sequencing
organization in partnership
with MIT, and
Harvard, and others.
And so these guys
were able to, using
Google Cloud and the mass amount
of compute that they have,
get the price of processing a
single genome down to under $5,
which is really tremendous
for making genome sequencing
accessible to the world
and letting you do things
like 23andMe, and so on.
And so when you
think about what it
takes to actually do this work,
it really costs, first of all,
a lot of money.
So that's why you saw
national laboratories owned
these systems.
To build these systems
at a massive scale
is really a huge undertaking,
not only in infrastructure,
but also in buildings,
and maintenance,
and everything like that.
But it's also very difficult to
run these systems efficiently.
So you can see on the right a
graph of typical utilization
in a system.
And blue is the total
capacity of your system,
where the red is jobs.
And so at a time of
very high utilization,
you have users sitting in the
queue waiting for their jobs
to run waiting for
other jobs to complete.
And on the right,
you can see times
when there aren't enough jobs,
and you're just wasting money
running your supercomputer.
And so this is a problem
even within Google.
But we've gotten
really, really good
at bin packing,
which is a term used
in HPC, which basically means
just utilizing your resources
very efficiently.
And so that's all
driven by Borg.
And so we'll talk a
little bit about how
we do this in Google Cloud.
And so to avoid having
to deal with all
of this on your
own system on prem,
you can really very easily
turn to Google Cloud for all
of our very easy,
fast provisioning,
our security, and our storage,
which we'll be talking
about a little bit more.
And so another user that
decided that it would probably
be a good idea to turn
to Google was Twitter.
And so you'll probably
hear at our keynotes
this week that Twitter
moved 300 petabytes of data
to Google Cloud Storage.
And they used Google Cloud and
decided on Google Cloud because
of all the reasons
that I just showed you
in terms of faster provisioning,
flexibility, and security.
So in terms of infrastructure
and what it actually
takes to run HPC--
very quickly before we dive
deeper into the HPC storage--
you really need three things.
That's compute, storage,
and networking, right?
So if we look at compute,
the fundamental driver
of compute in Google Cloud
is the Google Compute Engine.
And so Compute Engine
is really designed
to be powerful and flexible
for your workloads.
So we have up to 416
CPUs in a single machine,
12 terabytes of RAM, which you
just heard about this week.
We have Intel Optane
and local SSDs,
which we'll talk
about in a little bit.
But we also have
something that's
very key to HPC workloads
called custom machine types.
And so this is a
way that you can
size your instance,
choosing very specifically
the number of CPUs
and RAM that you
want to perfectly fit
every workload that you
run on Google Compute Engine.
So if you have one
system that needs
12 terabytes of RAM and 400
CPUs and GPUs, you can do that.
If you need one that needs 12
CPUs and 12 gigabytes of Ram,
you can build one.
We also have compute optimized
VMs, which are super high speed
CPU machines great for HPC.
We have GPUs, of course.
So we have Invidia K80s
all the way through T4s,
as well as TPUs, which
are awesome for machine
learning use cases.
Preemptible VMs
are an awesome tool
for running check-pointed
and quickly running code.
So they are up to 80% off
of a standard instance.
However they live for
a maximum of 24 hours
and can get preempted
anytime within that 24 hours
with 30 seconds of notice.
So again, check-pointed jobs,
jobs like genomic sequencing
where a single job
within a batch of jobs
can fail and be restarted is
perfect for preemptible VMs.
And then at the instance
level, networking scales,
in terms of bandwidth,
at two gigabits
per second per vCPU up to 16
gigabits per second per vCPU.
And we support
15,000 VMs per VPC.
So that's a lot of instances
on a single network.
If you need more than
that, let me know.
And speaking of networking,
in terms of the global network
that you need for massive
collaboration and massive data
storage, we have exactly that.
So we've invested billions
of dollars into our network.
And when you think
about a global network,
you have to think about
laying undersea cables
and dealing with things
like shark attacks, which
sharks like the electromagnetic
signals coming off
of the wires.
I don't know why.
So we have a
shark-proof network.
It's just one benefit.
And then finally, in
terms of compute storage,
we have a wide array of
local compute storage
options in terms of not only
Google Cloud Storage for object
storage, but also
persistent disk,
local storage like local
SSD, and then Filestore
and other solutions that
we'll be talking about just
in a little bit.
So to talk about HPC storage in
Google Cloud at a larger scale,
I'd like to introduce Dean.
DEAN HILDEBRAND:
Great, thanks Wyatt.
So what I wanted to talk
a little bit about is--
all right, now we're thinking
about doing HPC in the cloud.
In many cases, users already
have an HPC infrastructure,
like a compute-- you
know, a Linux cluster,
or a supercomputer, or something
in their existing premise.
They're not just coming
to this brand new.
But in a lot of cases,
that can happen, too.
So what you end up with is
a series of on-premise data
centers, each with
their own cluster,
and then connected into
a variety of Google Cloud
regions.
And so the trick then is how
do we get data into the regions
and back again?
And then once we
have the region up
and running, how do we
tailor make, I like to say,
the compute side and the
storage side for the workload
that you're trying to run?
So some of the common
models that we're
seeing from a
variety of HPC users
boils down into
three categories.
One of them is what I
like to call launch, which
is you're running maybe
Matlab or some smaller
program on your laptop or
on a desktop somewhere.
And you're not using
a lot of compute,
because it's just
a single machine
or a couple of machines.
But then you want to dynamically
burst your job into the cloud.
And so there are
partners that can
enable that where you're
using two cores here,
let's say, and you burst
out to 200 something.
And it becomes a very
dynamic real time
type bursting scenario.
Good for bursting compute, not
so good for bursting storage--
because if you're trying
to do this in real time,
you're going to wait
for that data transfer
to end up happening while you're
trying to dynamically burst.
The one that I see
a little more common
is the burst by
type, I like to say,
which is essentially
taking the workloads that
are running on premise
and splitting them up
into a set of categories.
And so two categories might be
the HPC high performance type
workloads that require
super low latency networks
and use MPI and a variety
of those kinds of tools,
and then separating that
out from the HTC, so
the high throughput computing,
which is more embarrassingly
parallel type jobs or
ensembles in some communities
where they're
running just millions
of smaller jobs on the system.
And so what you can do is then
leave the on premise system
that you have, optimize
that for one set of jobs--
let's say the HPC type jobs--
and then burst the
rest into the cloud,
and have the data stored
permanently up in the cloud.
And so you're really sort of
bifurcating your data plane,
but as well as your jobs.
And then that way
that enables you
to optimize-- instead of
having to optimize on premise
for every workload, small
IOPs and big bandwidth jobs,
you can really separate and
target each one individually.
And then the last
one, of course,
is all in, which is
obviously awesome and removes
the hassle of trying to do
data movement back and forth.
But I think that that's
more of a process in terms
of getting there all
the way to that phase.
So on the storage side,
then, what you end up with
is an on premise
data center that
probably has your Linux cluster
running and your own storage
system.
And then you have a
set of file systems
that you might want to
target inside the cloud.
So here, just as an example,
I have our Google Cloud
Filestore.
And then we have a Lustre
system in the system.
And so first you can
see that we can tailor
make the compute side of
each of these clusters
to whatever the workload is.
So Filestore is a smaller
NFS based offering.
So you'd have a
smaller set of nodes
that would be accessing that
with whatever number of CPUs
that they require,
and tailor making then
the storage in Filestore for
whatever the requirements are.
And then we have the
other one, as well,
on the larger compute cluster
that you're going to have,
and then targeting a Lustre
system that's optimized
for whatever the workload is--
high bandwidth, high IOPs,
or whatever is needed.
And then the challenge
becomes how do you
get the data back and forth?
And so a lot of cases people
are using Cloud storage
in the middle for
that data transfer.
Because it provides the
secure and high bandwidth
pipe that you basically need
in order to get the data up.
And then from cloud storage, you
can then essentially burst out
into your file systems.
And then the results
can then flow back
the other way, as needed.
So talking a little bit about
our Cloud Storage offering--
I think most of you might
already know about it--
but essentially, it can
be used for a variety
of different purposes.
You can use it as your
production HPC storage
offering.
Or you can also just use it
as a cold tire and store,
essentially, the cold
data in your system
and save money by
keeping it there.
Or you can just use it as,
again, a transitory place
to copy data in and out as
data is flowing back and forth
from your on premise system.
And so Cloud Storage
is obviously awesome.
And it can do amazing things.
And it can scale
across the globe.
But in many cases what
you end up with is still
your applications are
not written for that.
And if you're
writing applications
for on premise supercomputers
or Linux clusters,
you probably are not
writing applications
for object storage,
in which case,
you end up with needing
some sort of file storage.
And so I ask this
question, well,
what do you mean, file
systems in the cloud?
You know, we're
going to modernize.
This old file system
stuff, you know,
POSIX is from 50 years ago.
Like why are we there?
But the thing is, as I
said, many HPC workflows
that are running today rely
on a POSIX based file system.
They rely on the performance.
And they also rely on
the types of behaviors
that file storage can support,
such as in place updates,
handling large numbers
of small files,
because they deliver latencies
that are sub-millisecond versus
the tens of milliseconds that
object cloud storage provides.
And the other thing that
I like to remind people
is that file is actually
very cloud friendly.
NFS says the concept
is built into Linux.
And it's available from
every VM that you launch.
And it's a core part of the
Kubernetes infrastructure.
And you can dynamically
use NFS in Kubernetes
just without doing
any work whatsoever.
And so it's also very
friendly to preemptible
VMs, which is another core part
of HPC, as Wyatt brought up.
And obviously, very
familiar, right-- all of us
understand what file is.
We do this on our
laptops every day.
These are the apps that we
learned to write in university.
And so it's just
something that becomes
a very natural transition.
So what I wanted to do then
is go into some of the details
that--
OK, so you're going
to use the cloud.
You're going to deploy a larger
file system inside the cloud.
Going through some of the
just general bare bones
ways on how GCP works in
terms of compute and storage--
so at the top there, we
have our compute VMs.
And so something,
as Wyatt said, you
need to choose the
right number of vCPUs,
or if you're GPUs or TPUs--
whatever the infrastructure you
need for your compute layer.
But then these nodes are
also your file system client,
whether it's NFS or a POSIX
based client such as Lustre.
And so you need to
make sure that it
has the bandwidth it needs.
And so at the two
gigabits per vCPU,
you always need to make sure
that you have enough of those
to at least deliver the
network performance.
Even if you didn't
need them, you're
going to need them for
the network, I'm sure.
So the next step, then,
is the storage servers.
So these file system
clients are then
using some level
of distributed IO
across a set of storage servers
that you're going to launch.
And these end up being VMs
inside of Google Cloud,
as well.
So you need to keep the
same things in mind.
The one is the networking.
There's no point in
putting up a whole bunch
of small VMs in many cases.
You're going to want to
have the largest network
capacity possible.
So you're going to want
to think about at least
eight cores for those servers.
And you might then want
to think about, well,
does the file system support
some level of extra caching
where we could put
in some local SSDs?
How much RAM do we
want to support?
And all of that
can be configurable
depending on the type of
job that you're using.
So then finally,
there's going to be
some storage, would be the
point of the file system.
And so if you're going to
store this data durably,
you're going to be
using persistent disk.
And then there's a few things
that you need to watch out
there for, as well.
And so one of them is that the
performance scales linearly
with capacity.
So you can look at your
capacity requirements.
And then you have to look at
your performance requirements.
And then you need to choose
the capacity-- provision
the capacity that
meets both of those.
So some people don't like
paying for extra capacity
if you're not going to use it.
But don't think of it that way.
Think of it as you're
paying for performance.
And some of that
is just logical.
I mean you can't have--
the more capacity it has, the
more spindles or the more SSDs
you're engaging,
which means then you
have-- enables more bandwidth
and IOPs into the system.
So it works very similarly onto
how on premise systems work.
The other thing to remember
is that with PD-SSD there
is a set of vCPU requirements.
And that's because the
high IOP of using SSDs just
drives cores.
And so it's a tiered system.
But you get the best
performance with using 32 vCPUs
at that level.
And then the other
thing is to remember
is that they scale linearly.
But then they hit different
limits at different capacities.
And so it's easier just to
choose the largest capacity.
And then you don't have to
worry about whether or not
you could somehow have
eked out performance.
But some of the common
mistakes I've seen
is where they choose smaller
VMs and smaller capacities,
and then they have
a lot of them.
And it's just a lot
easier to shrink
the number of VMs and storage
servers that you're deploying
and maximize out the bandwidth
and the IOPs of each of them.
All right, so we have a lot
of storage options in Google.
And it can be quite confusing
in terms of figuring out
which ones are right for you.
The top row here is the
structured storage options,
which I always like to put up.
But we're focusing in on
the bottom ones today.
And so we talked a little
bit about Cloud Storage
and Persistent Disk.
And I'll mention
Filestore briefly.
But then we also have a
set of HPC storage partners
that we're partnering
with and are putting up
different levels of file
systems inside of Google
that are really targeted
towards these HPC use cases.
So the first one to talk about
is Google's own Filestore.
So this is great for small to
medium sized jobs, like I said,
maybe a Matlab job or some
sort of smaller test system
that you're running.
And it's fully managed
and NFS based from Google.
Next, if you need to
go bigger than that,
elastifile is putting up a
fully managed NFS space scale
out file system that
really is targeted
as the next tier of
Filestore and delivers
a really great number of IOPs.
So if you have a
high IOP workload,
then this is a great choice.
And of course, we have our
Netapp Cloud Volume Service.
And so with them you
get all the performance
that you normally expect out
of using Netapp on premise.
But you get it with
all of the integration
and the ease of use of GCP.
And so it's just
like the other two.
It's fully integrated into the
console and the billing system.
And you can just
dynamically use it
as if you were using
any of the other storage
options in Google.
And so we are also developing
now a partnership with DDN
around their Lustre service and
their other software storage
offerings.
And so now I'm going to
pass it off to Sven from DDN
to talk about that.
SVEN OEHME: Hello, my
name is Sven Oehme.
I'm the chief research
officer for DDN.
With me is Minh, one of our
senior software developers.
Let me swipe to the next slide.
So since this week, we actually
announced on the marketplace
a new offering.
DDN acquired last
year Whamcloud,
which was Intel's division
that was running the Lustre
development organization.
So DDN now essentially owns
the majority of all Lustre
developers worldwide.
So we brought a service online.
Minh was instrumental
in actually get this up
and running.
So while I'm speaking and
talking over the next slides,
I'm going to pass it over
to Minh for a second.
He's going to start a demo to
show you how easy it actually
is to deploy this
on Google Cloud.
And while the-- basically the
deployment in the background
is running, I'm going to talk
about the rest of the slides.
MINH DIEP: Thanks, Sven.
So the Lustre solution,
the easiest place to find
is on the marketplace.
So we just need to
search for Lustre.
And here is our
offering, Lustre on GCP.
And as you see, it's similar
to any other offering.
So when we launch--
keep in mind that this solution
is along multiple instances.
So you may want to
plan ahead of time.
But we do provide step by step
and predefined profile for you
to just launch the easiest.
So all you need is
a couple of steps.
So the deployment name
is already pre-filled.
If you have one
deployed already,
it will change this deployment
name to a different one.
The zone, you can
select your zone.
And the network, by default,
it just picks whatever network
that your zone's in.
One thing that you
might want to consider
is using the private Lustre
network that you're choosing.
So for this demo, I
am going just arrange.
And if you want
to access directly
to your cluster from outside,
you can just pick external IP,
automatically allocate for you.
Or you can just select None.
And it will create a
rounder so that you
can have a gateway to
jump into before you
go into your cluster.
File system name,
you can change it.
Here is something that we have
predefined a couple of profiles
to help a new user or user
have different level of need.
So quick start is pretty
small, standard, standard plus
and premium.
For today's demo, I am going
to just select the premium.
And it also can be
a capacity based,
where each profile has a minimum
requirement for capacity.
So if you want to increase more
than that, you just enter here.
And step four, if you
don't select any profile
on step three, you
can go into step four
and make change to your
server anyway you want.
Some people they want
to tailor it to the way
that they want it,
be a certain server,
a certain memory-- you can do
all that customization here.
The last step is select
number of clients
included into this deploy.
So for our purpose, I
picked eight client.
And the last step is
just click deploy.
And the deployment
approximately on this deploy
is about four minutes.
So while we are waiting
for the deployment,
I will hand back to Sven.
And we'll come back
to here when it's
complete in about
four or five minutes.
And we'll continue.
SVEN OEHME: Yeah,
thanks a lot, Minh.
So a couple of things
to mention is probably
there is a default eight
by five support associated
with the service.
So you can actually
pick up the phone
and call somebody if
there's a problem.
It is not fully managed yet.
We are looking for
feedback from customers
if they also want a fully
managed service of that.
And then we're going
to look into this.
And so if you deploy the
system, as Minh said,
this is probably going to take
somewhere around four minutes.
We also deployed large systems
of hundreds of terabytes
in size.
And everything is
basically a matter
of a couple of minutes
to get deployed.
So it's actually-- it's pretty
easy and pretty scalable
if you need a very large amount
of capacity in the cloud.
So let's talk a little
bit more about Lustre
and what DDN is actually
bringing to the table here.
So DDN's Lustre is the number
world [INAUDIBLE] system
deployed.
We have a large number
of AI customers.
So we're not just
playing in HPC.
We have very specific offerings
in the AI space, as well.
And the whole purpose
of Lustre is really
to provide very,
very high performance
where traditional file serving
solutions typically lack in.
So why we can do a lot of
things with NFS and SMP
with normal workloads--
as soon as we
get to massive amount
of parallelism,
they are typically not really
your choice of workloads.
So we have some customers
today deployed in the world--
if you look at the top
500 supercomputing list,
a massive amount of them are
actually running the Lustre
file system inside.
So there is a very interesting
performance benchmark
called IO 500.
I'm talking a little
bit more about that.
And what we see
here is essentially
it demonstrates the
capabilities of that offering.
So we have customers that have
millions or billions of files.
We can do hundreds of
gigabytes, even terabytes
per second throughput
with this technology.
It's something that is
really provably deployed
in many, many sites.
So we basically try to bring
this on prem technology
that we deploy in
many, many sites
today in the cloud to
give customers the choice
to not just run this on prem,
but also get a very, very
nice cloud experience with a
very proven technology that
is deployed in many
of these areas today.
So the things that
primarily differentiate
Lustre from some of
these other options
that you see on the
marketplace is really
superiority and scalability.
As I just said, deploying
hundreds of millions,
even billions of files,
petabyte size systems--
we have some systems
on prem today
that are three digits
petabytes in size.
So we know that the
technology scales.
So we can deploy this in the
cloud with the same technology.
The other nice thing is that
you can very nicely scale it
for various types of workloads.
It doesn't matter if you have
massive random read performance
workloads or you have massively
sequential workloads for reads
over writes.
We have small files
or large files.
There is lots of options
that you can have.
We try to keep it as
simple as possible.
That's why we have all
these profiles where you
can basically pre-select from.
But if you need
something that is highly
tailored for your
environment, you
can do this with the
offering, as well.
And what a lot of people don't
know is many AI workloads,
particularly-- and we really put
lots of effort in this area--
rely under the cover on mmap().
So many, many libraries,
LMDB and multiple others,
use mmap() under the cover.
Many other file system
options actually
have significant performance
scaling issues with that.
And so we put lots of
investment into this area
to make this very, very fast.
So we believe that's why this
option is very interesting,
particularly if you try to
run AI workloads in the cloud.
Because with a distributed file
system that has optimizations
for that, a lot of the
frameworks that basically get
shipped out of the box on
these systems are going to run
significantly faster if
they leverage mmap() under
the cover.
We also have-- given the size of
the deployments we already had,
there is lots of expertise
in the organization
to manage massively
scalable systems.
We actually run for lots
of customers very massively
scaled systems on site.
So we provide these extra
services to customers on prem.
And basically, with the service
offering and the knowledge
that we have in this area,
we try to bring all of that
into the cloud, as well.
And we are more
than happy to also
have separate engagements
in specialized services
for that if there are very
specific needs you have.
So the technology is
heavily being worked on.
We tried to tailor, as
I said, this offering
specifically for cloud.
There is lots of
powerful tools that we
are in the process of launching
in subsequent releases that
are going to come over the
next couple of quarters.
So you have, today, already
capabilities to set a quota
allocation in the system.
You can either do
this by sub-directory,
there is options you can do
this by user or by group.
And we going to add
significant management
capabilities in
terms of pooling.
So we have much more
fine-grained control as an end
user or based on data that the
system automatically collects
in terms of file heat and being
able to basically manage data
placement across multiple pools
of different types of storage
inside the system at basically--
with the full automatism and
the tools required for the end
users to manage that.
We also have a capability
for doing very fast transfers
from on prem to cloud.
Because it's great if you
have an offering on the cloud
or if you have an
offering on the prem.
But if you can't figure out
how to make the movement
for these very, very large
scale systems working,
you need more than that.
And we have a special
product, which I
have one extra slide for that.
And there's auditing
capabilities, as well,
that is required, obviously,
for lots of customers
for governance purposes.
And we have lots of security
features into this solution,
as well.
So you can do things
like secure mounts
where people only can mount
certain sub-directories
of the system without other
people essentially seeing
the data of each other.
So we can basically separate
each other's out in the file
[INAUDIBLE] namespace.
So IO500, as I said,
it's a benchmark
that is used trying
to provide, basically,
a very fair comparison between
different storage solutions
in the market out there.
We've done a couple of tests
in the IO500 benchmark.
With Lustre, this is just one
example of what we deployed.
We basically deployed 120 client
system, 120 service system,
with 180 terabyte
capacity in total.
We achieved 107 gigabytes
per second throughput
on the system.
And we basically showed
absolute linear scalability
going from the
smallest configuration
we've tested all the way up.
And as Minh already
mentioned, and what
we're going to show in
the demo in a few seconds,
is that all of this was
launched, essentially,
and executed in a
couple of minutes.
These are the results
of the benchmarks.
So we did different tests.
So we scaled service
independently of client.
So this is essentially the
Lustre server count scaling.
So you see the IO500
score, how it basically
goes up when we add servers.
I have to mention one
point-- the benchmark
itself is very complicated.
So as large you make the
benchmark data size as more
complex its execution is.
And so as higher you go,
basically, in the scores,
the tougher it's going
to be if you increase
the scale of the system.
And we also, as I said,
increased the gigabytes
per second, essentially by
just adding individual nodes
into the system.
So here you see the
scale basically going
from 10 servers, to 60
servers, to 120 servers.
And you see basically a very
nice scale of that performance
in the system.
And we believe if you just add
more nodes into the system,
it's just basically going to
run faster and faster as more
resources you add into this.
So the nice thing
is, as I said, you
can scale capacity completely
independent from metadata
and independent of the IOPs
or throughput in the system.
So basically whatever
metrics you try to achieve,
it's just basically a matter
of picking the right input
for the deployment.
And we can basically
meet all of those needs.
So two more slides
that are very specific.
I said this is our
cloud offering.
Lots of our customers already
have on prem offering.
Or customers that
have a cloud offering
also need an on prem offering.
So I want to show you
two slides of what
we deploy to the on prem.
So we've just launched
a new product.
It's called SFA18K.
It's essentially the
fastest storage controller
for file systems that you
can purchase right now.
It's essentially
a 4U device that
delivers 80 gigabytes per second
throughput over the network.
And this is essentially embedded
running the same Lustre file
system software that
we deploy on GCP.
So if you're looking
for an offering that
needs to be deployed
on prem, this
is a very, very good
offering for that.
And the second slide
that I wanted to show you
is a product called Dataflow.
So this is the one
that essentially
ties this on prem technology
with the cloud technology,
or the cloud to cloud,
or on prem to on prem.
So the product's
called Dataflow.
And what Dataflow
essentially does,
it tightly integrates with
multiple storage sources
and targets.
So it's not actually limited to
just Lustre on prem and Lustre
on the cloud.
It has targets to NFS.
It has targets to SMB.
It has targets to IBM
Spectrum Scale file system.
It has targets to
multiple different sources
and targets including S3, and
even has support for Tape.
And what differentiates
this technology
from other simple file movement
or data management solutions
is that it's particularly
built for massive scale.
So you can basically take
a 100 petabytes system
as a source and a multi--
hundreds of terabytes
or petabytes
file system in the cloud.
And you can basically
fan out the data movement
across large number of nodes
and large number of networks.
So instead of running
on a single node,
it's essentially going to send
a request to the source system.
You specify with rules what
data you want to be moved.
It finds this data
very fast with built
in technologies in that
technology if it's supported.
So
For example, if you run this
against a Spectrum Scale
cluster from IBM, it's
going to use the policy
engine that is built in there.
It's going to find the files
very quickly that you select,
then splits the workload across
large number of workloads
and transfers them in
parallel into the cloud.
Because that's one
of the big challenges
with these massive
data movements.
How do you move that data
between cloud and on prem.
And you can't really do
this from a single node
you need a massively distributed
system in order to do that.
And basically Dataflow
is providing you
exactly that capability
to move between all
these different technologies.
MINH DIEP: OK, so
there was the screen
last we left when
it finished deploy
approximately four
to five minute
on this particular profile.
So as you can see on
the right hand side,
you see some information.
What we provide is a web
console that you can see file--
you can see your statistic.
Or you can see status of
your Lustre file system.
So this will display the Lustre
network, file system name,
also the NID, the network
LNET NID that you use.
If you have new client
bringing in to mount,
that is the mount point
that you want to use.
So all information is there.
And we are running the
latest version of Lustre--
2.12.0 and the [INAUDIBLE] 7.6.
And below here is the
information that you can
automatically-- we have--
automate the way that
you can introduce
new cluster, a new client into
mounting the same file system.
So you can read all that.
But one interesting--
I want to show
you is that if you
visit the console,
you will see a
Lustre file system.
And you see metadata.
And you see the object storage
target that we just allocate.
And the total file system,
just for this demo,
I just launched 25 per terabyte
with using a few minutes.
And the cluster,
here are showing
the OSS, which is its server.
And we are using
approximately 10 OSS.
And on the right hand side
are these read and write.
Right now I think it's
doing-- the read-- what I just
did was I launched an
IOR program on client
to demonstrate this activity.
So you can see that
this reading at 400
megabytes per second right now.
And if we go to the
graph we include in
the [INAUDIBLE] graph, you
can monitor this statistic
for last hour, or day, or week.
So you have metadata server,
management server, and OSS.
So I want to show you the--
so we have 10 OSS.
The first default
screen is going
to be the load of the OSS.
So you can see the
load just spike up.
Because we just
launched an IOR test.
One of the interesting thing--
I mean, you can see
a lot of statistics,
create, write, read
for individual OST
if you want to look at it.
But we'll look at
the total byte read
and write total on all of them.
And they do a stacked graph
with 10 different colors.
And you can see, if you
click on individual one,
you can actually see
everything CPU, low luster.
Let me see.
We can collapse.
And we can look
at the OST matrix.
All the statistic is
there for you to look.
And while you run
your application,
you can actually see
the low, everything.
So I think that--
SVEN OEHME: Yeah.
So as you can see, there's
lots of detailed information
that we expose.
So it's very easy to also
find potential bottlenecks
where you might
actually be limited by--
like, if you know exactly
what the network limit is
of the individual instance,
you know that when
you deploy a larger system or
expand it what you basically
have to pay attention for.
Minh, thanks a lot for the demo.
And I'm going to
hand it back to you.
DEAN HILDEBRAND: Thanks, Sven.
Thanks, Minh.
So I think this is
where we want to get to,
right, is you have your way--
you know, there's-- the last 30
years has been optimizing how
people are doing HPC on premise,
and how they're deploying file
systems, and, you know,
DDN's the experts there,
and compute servers, and all
these things it in the cloud.
So we're trying to
get to, well, what's
the best way to do it there?
And so we really want to change
some of the general dynamics
around one massive file system
that you're just bin packing
all of your workloads
into and really sort
of thinking about how do we
optimize the entire workflow
where you're expanding the
clusters when you need to,
you're shrinking them down
when they're not needed,
you're targeting
file systems where
you can set of jobs for
bandwidth that are bandwidth
optimized, and you can set a set
of jobs that require high IOPs
and really targeting
the specific needs
of the applications by doing
the right configuration
within Google.
[MUSIC PLAYING]